Let's introduce one more feature into our list comprehensions.
Remember ta_data and ta_facts.
When we ran this, we got a list of strings
which each contained a fact about a TA.
Like: Job lives in the USA,
and is the TA for CS387.
Well, what if we only want facts about TAs that don't live in the USA?
So, in this case that would be Gundega and Sarah.
Well, since these TAs are working remotely,
let's call it remotetafacts,
and all we have to do is add a simple "if" statement.
And now when we run this, we only get these two strings
about Sarah and Gundega.
The addition we made was pretty intuitive.
This "if" statement just says: "If the country is not the USA,"
then we're going to add an entry
according to the rules we described earlier.
I hope you learned a lot about list comprehensions.
You should feel free to click the link below the video to learn even more,
but now it's time to practice.